[Music]
good morning to you it's seven o'clock
you're watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster new detail this
morning
on how the government plans to fight the
threat of variance
the vaccine's minister nadim zahawi is
with us shortly plus we'll talk to the
shadow worker pension secretary
jonathan reynolds also for you today
rock on the green list as expectant
holiday makers await news of the
government's new travel rules
we'll speak to the chief minister of
gibraltar about their hopes to welcome
british travelers this summer
[Music]
we're joined by none other than the yawn
ulvaeus from abba
a half past eight can you believe it as
artists sound an sos
call over the financial implications of
music streaming
it's wednesday the 5th of
do may have anything to say to
manchester united fans mr glazer
is it time to sell the club mr glazer
no words we track down man united's
billionaire boss in florida as fans
demand a response
super labs new plans to boost our fight
against cobit variants
tributes to the community support
officer murdered in
kent but what clues to catch her killer
will bring the latest from the scene
sparks fly french minister threatens to
cut off
jersey's electricity supply in a row
over post-brexit
fishing rights california's
cracked earth we investigate the visible
impact of climate change after the
state's driest year
for nearly a century and painting a
picture of family life
megan reveals her latest project
and another showery day and
disappointingly cool for this time of
the year but it does look like
temperatures will be rising for some
later in the week i'll have the details
for you later
now very good morning to you thousands
of miles from old trafford where
manchester united fans stormed the pitch
during
protests this weekend sky news has
tracked down one of the club's
billionaire bosses to ask if he wants to
say sorry
united fans who've long harbored
resentment for their billionaire
american owners
have renewed calls for the glazer family
to sell the club
after the botched move to join the
european super league
sally lockwood reports from florida
the anger of fans can no longer be
ignored by manchester united's owners
protesters at old trafford forcing
sunday's game
to be called but more than four thousand
miles away
in palm beach florida are the american
owners
listening we found avraham glazer who
owns the club with his brother joel
do you have anything to say to
manchester united fans mr glazer
is it time to sell the club mr glazer
nothing to say at all are the fans just
customers to you
is the customer always right mr glazer
nothing to say at all to the fans of
manchester united mr glazer
this is an opportunity for you
an apology perhaps
fans are calling for dialogue with the
glazers to avoid further protests that
forced the game against liverpool to be
scrapped
there's been opposition to the glazer
family's ownership of manchester united
since they bought the club 16 years ago
but their attempt to form the failed
european
super league has refocused a rage
towards the owners
the big big people at the top don't
really seem to care about what
what the little people have to say but
it's just rubbish
really like rubbish in it in their eyes
i think manchester united support is
under relevance
uh you know they're obviously interested
in making as much money as they can
and the only people that the glaciers
fear are the politicians
certainly here in the billionaire
enclave of palm beach
the fan relationship with its owners
couldn't feel more distant
manchester united supporters trust has
written an open letter to joel glazer
demanding a response by friday they say
no member of the family has ever had so
much as a conversation with them
the fans just customers to you mr glazer
certainly for now
the club's co-owner avram glazer had
nothing to say sally lockwood sky news
in palm beach florida
now the government is to invest nearly
30 million pounds in new labs and
testing at its port and down facility
to assess the effectiveness of
coronavirus vaccines against
new variants now it's hope this is going
to speed up the deployment of
vaccines which are tailored to tackle
variants of concern well let's talk to
the vaccines minister
nadim zahawi good to see you this
morning so this additional 30 million
looks like
almost 50 million pounds invested in
portland down
since september i mean in real terms
what difference is this going to make
so back in september uh the facility
could test about 700
blood samples every week
we made a 20 million just shy of 20
million investment
in there to raise that to 1500 blood
samples every week
and we're going further what we're
announcing today is a further
just shy of 30 million so bringing the
investment totaled 50 million
to take that scale from 700
tests a week to 3 000 plus sample tests
a week all part of our future proofing
as the secretary of state for health
said in terms
of always being ahead of the virus
as it mutates to survive we need to make
sure that we have
vaccine variants that are ready for any
virus variant
that may escape the good news is the
current vaccination
program and the vaccines we're deploying
are working effectively against the
dominant
virus in the united kingdom what about
the time scale
in all of this i mean what difference is
it going to make in the
next few months when obviously we've got
these real concerns about variants
coming through
how quickly can these new labs new
facilities be online
so this new investment will deliver in
january of next year but we also have
uh a capability to genome sequence in
the united kingdom that is
one of the largest what we account for
just shy of 50
of all the sequencing being done of the
different virus mutations
in the world and of course a few weeks
ago we made that big offer
to other countries where they don't have
that capability genome sequence to do
that for them to hold a library so
the deal we announced with cure vac with
the messenger rna vaccine in the uk is
to
effectively give them a library of all
the virus
variants mutations so that they can be
ready with a messenger rna
vaccine for us as well of course the
investment we're making
in val never in scotland which is a
whole inactivated
virus that makes up the the vaccine so
a lot of work both with the current
manufacturers we're talking to
astrozenic and oxford team about a
vaccine variant
we've bought 60 million of pfizer we're
talking to moderna
about their vaccine variant as well as
of course this investment today to make
sure that
we've got the laboratory analysis to do
this work in the uk so we stay we remain
now ahead of the virus all the time what
about i mean
this must have been in play these plans
must have been in play for some time why
announce them
today the day before local and mayoral
elections
uh the honest truth is until you make
the investment
and they're ready yeah we we we announce
when we sign when we
actually when the system is ready to
accept
that investment when the plans are
signed off so
um you know ministers and i i hear the
cynicism in your in your voice
ministers have have very little to do
with with the timing it's all about
making sure we back our scientists we
back
uh public health england we back the
team at port and down have done
an amazing job uh through this pandemic
but the the the principle of this is to
future proof
the uh vaccination program uh for
the autumn and then for years to come
because as we move
hopefully from pandemic to endemic this
will be similar to the sort of annual
flu vaccination program where
the scientists will decide as they do at
who
which variants are the most concerned
and then we we effectively formulate a
vaccine to deal with those where does
this leave us in terms of vaccine
diplomacy
because i mean obviously what you're
saying is is that the new work at
portland and is going to have a global
impact
which is welcome but in terms of
immediate things we can do the us
is now sending 10 of the united states
produced vaccines
by other countries by start of start of
july
do we need to start making similar
commitments now
so let me just place on record for your
viewers
the oxford astrozenica vaccine
way back from last year and
the oxford team and astrazeneca
licensing that vaccine
to the serum institute for example in
india at
zero profit has meant that they will
produce with uk funding we've put
over half a billion pounds into kovacs a
billion doses
for low income and middle a billion
doses so
put that into perspective of all the
other donations that are taking place
that's a big big
number already over 40 million doses
have arrived in
ghana and the ivory coast and the
philippines
the bulk of that is the asparagus oxford
vaccine
it's great news that albert baller and
pfizer are doing the same thing
putting more through kovacs but we will
go further as well
uh in terms of the prime minister and
the foreign secretary
uh have already talked about our
commitment to kovacs in terms of
excess vaccines and of course the help
to india where we've already delivered
first tranche was 600 i think 400
ventilators 200 and
oxygen concentrators three big or three
mini oxygen factories and a further 1
000 ventilators
so we're doing both the work on vaccines
and on helping in the of course on
vital medical equipment that they need
to deal with the current
spike that they're sadly facing in in
terms of vaccines that we need in this
country i mean there's obviously
now looks like this booster is going to
go i mean certainly for the over 50s in
the autumn and
possibly wider reaching than that we've
ordered the 60 million doses of pfizer
to cover the booster
why pfizer and not astrazeneca for the
booster so this is
really important what we will do in the
vaccines task force is make sure that
the
scientist chris whitty the chief medical
officer with his
fellow chief medical officers from wales
scotland and northern ireland
will make that decision at the moment
they're still looking
at the data to see whether the
durability of the
current vaccination program how far it
lasts
but we want them to be able if they need
to from september onwards
to boost those that are most vulnerable
so if you remember we've
vaccinated the residence of care homes
the over 80s over 75s over 70s
and those that are clinically extremely
vulnerable now
pfizer is one option we are going to
give them an astrozenica oxford option
we're working with the team
on an on a vaccine variant novavax is
another option
which has been manufactured in t-side
filled and finished at barnard castle
that works very well against both the
south african variant and the
kent variant and of course valeneva in
scotland
and curvac that i talked about but they
haven't made that decision yet it's very
important for your viewers to know
that the clinicians haven't yet made a
decision when they will
need to boost whether to give more more
immunity to the most vulnerable to
increase the durability of the
protection
or to deal with a variant when they
decide i want to give them
as much optionality as many vaccines
that work then they will make those
choices there is a clinical trial that
jonathan van tam is conducting
which looks at which vaccine delivers
the best boost
so it's not just pfizer it could be
astrazeneca it could be
novavax could be the valeneva vaccine
so all that work is happening right now
so that when the clinicians say go
the nhs is putting plans in place now
to deploy from september onwards if
needed it may not be september it could
be maybe later in the year or
early next year but the nhs has plans
they need to dovetail of course with the
flu vaccination program because we've
been to flu season
by then all that work we're doing right
now
to make sure we're future-proof the the
sort of the short-term boost and then
the longer-term annual covered slash
flu vaccination program um yesterday i
was talking uh about the the g7 summit
the in-person meeting and we called it a
covid secure meeting and i said on there
well
of course it's a covent secure meeting
there's been a there's been a covert
scare
hasn't there at the g7 do we know how
many members of the delegation
are self-isolating i don't um
i'm afraid but um obviously you know
public health england
and the team that are organizing the g7
take
this very seriously as you saw the
pictures you were you were broadcasting
the pictures yesterday
of the different delegations uh being
tested so
we continue to have one of the most
robust
um uh set of protocols around
testing uh and so we we we will make
sure
that happens but i don't know the
numbers so uh so so there has been a
schedule you know if anyone was testing
possibilities this is news to me i mean
you're telling me this
as as as we speak so i i i can't really
comment on this
right right well we again waiting for
absolute confirmation but
one of the special advisors was
indicating this this was the case so
but we will be fully you know fully
across that and do whatever take
whatever measures are necessary
absolutely um can we move on to
brexit um because of the the situation
we've got with with jersey now and
there's a row over fishing rights
uh with around the jersey territorial
waters and
france now saying they they are willing
to cut off power supply to jersey
if this route isn't sorted out what do
you make of that
well i think the on the positive side
it was really good to see the european
parliament ratify what i think is an
historic
agreement between the united kingdom and
our eu
neighbours uh that was really important
that that happened at the end of
uh last month that was a big
um moving on moving forward i should say
the important thing i think is that both
sides uh
david frost and of course his
counterparts
now continue to work together to make
sure that operationally
on the ground we iron out
any issues any problems so that this
historic deal between the united kingdom
and the eu one of the most important
deals
we have struck we've put in place works
for people for communities for the
uh fishing communities for other people
and i think
uh my my very strong
um uh uh feeling on this is that
we need to work constructively and
actually people are working structurally
on both sides but when
when france is turning around saying
they're prepared to turn the lights off
on jersey i mean that that's not very
diplomatic is it i mean do we need to
look at what we're doing and
they're accusing us of using red tape to
limit their their fishing ability i mean
we
we've got to look at this urgently well
as i say this is
an issue for the commission to work with
our team with david frost
and all the indications from
minister frost and his team is that the
commission is taking seriously
some of these um operational
challenges that we need to fix together
that's the best way to do this
in the same way we're doing now on uh
our vaccine program it's great to see
spain and france and germany really
begin to accelerate the vaccination
program
we send millions of the the the
nanoparticles that carry the fisa
messenger rna
that delivers those jabs from a great
business called croda in the uk
to the eu and they send us back uh both
the the pfizer vaccine and of course uh
other
uh uh vaccines and you know we it's much
better to work together
on this stuff than it is to to uh in
some you know
to allow some of these operational
challenges to become confrontational in
terms of europe a lot of us are wanting
to go there
in in the summer um some of this is
going to be dependent
on the getting the nhs app to be
to have uh vaccination certificates or
uh test certification on board that's
gonna happen
quickly we need it for the 17th of may
we understand that there's a
struggling to get that done in time is
is that right how how soon can we expect
that to be working
well the team under nhs x that's leading
on this mata gould is
i think doing a really important job
they're already piloting
we had a pilot in kettering hospital on
this
the app is one uh part of the
certification
process so very important that people
have the capability
uh to be able to demonstrate they've had
a test as we require other
uh essential travel from non-red list
countries of course because what 40
countries on the red list
to have a a pre-departure test we have
the same thing so we have got to be able
to show it
but also physically some people don't
have a smartphone
and we are making that nhs will make
that provision also available and i'm
confident
they'll be able to deliver on that the
important thing is that the transport
secretary grant staff is actually
leading his g7 colleagues to
essentially agree the protocols for
travel around the world
because what you want is a global
protocol that works for our citizens
that we can shape which is why the work
that he's doing and he'll say a bit
more on this at the end of this week in
terms obviously the
traffic light system of countries that
are green amber or red
okay minister good to see you as always
thank you great to see you
now still to come on the program this
morning and as labour prepares for the
largest set of elections
ever held outside your general election
we're joined by the shadow work and
pension secretary
jonathan reynolds shortly after half
past seven
the environmental impact of filling your
house with plans we'll find out more
with a member
of the royal horticultural society
that's at 20 to 9.
and building support ahead of the tokyo
olympics will speak to roa helen glover
and endurance athlete jamie ramsey at a
quarter to 10.
now let's get some analysis uh what the
minister was saying this morning talk to
our political correspondent joe pike
what did you think joe interesting on
booster jabs we know that there is this
programme of
third doses i suppose people coming this
autumn there's even a highway saying i
mean
the questions are still to be answered
over what that booster is focused on is
it about the jura
durability of the vaccine protection is
it about
protecting people from new variants
that's sort of not decided i think that
is fascinating we'll hear more about
that
in the coming months on vaccine
diplomacy we know the u.s
are exporting large numbers of vaccine
tens of millions of
vaccine doses museums are we keen to
talk about
the uk exporting the science but not
doses but implying perhaps
that boris johnson and uh dominic rob
the foreign secretary may have more
announcements on this
russia are certainly exporting their own
vaccines they think it does
uh good things for their international
reputation well we do the same
not much on holidays i think we'll have
to wait until grant chap speaks on
friday
and on jersey this row uh over
axed the fishing waters between france
and the jersey government
with the french maritime minister
threatening to cut off electricity
saying we'll work constructively on both
sides finally on the fact that the
vaccine minister was on tv today and
announcing new money for vaccines just a
day before
the significant election some may say
that is no coincidence
the government want this vaccine bounce
tomorrow and therefore they're sort of
engineering this to help that he was
saying ministers have very little to do
with
the uh the timing of this the honest
truth is that the plans were announced
when they were signed off well
i'm not sure i completely believe he
accused us of being cynical joe okay i
know
it i know who defunk it joe thank you
now candles have been lit and flowers
laid
in memory of the murdered community
support officer
officer julia james in kent police are
still
hunting her killer more than a week
since her body
was discovered well let's talk to our
correspondent
ender brady who joins us now from the
scene and
we just where is the investigation at
this stage
good morning stephen well this is day
eight of this murder investigation we're
in aylesham in kent about half a mile
away from where
julia james's body was discovered on
tuesday of last week she'd been walking
her dog
while she was attacked now what has
happened overnight is that her family
had asked people that rather than gather
for a vigil to simply light a candle on
their doorstep and many many people in
this community did
just that and the prime minister took to
social media last night
to pay tribute to julia james i'm
reading some of the messages left behind
me here many many dozens of floral
tributes
in this park here this marketplace area
in aylesham
the one thing that really shines through
is just how respected and popular julia
was
in this community and one message simply
reads from your police family
we will get you justice so the search
for her killer
continuing today day eight of this
murder investigation
ken police have not made any arrests yet
they say they are not ruling out
any motives they are exploring all
avenues and they're urging the public in
this area
to be vigilant remain cautious and if
anyone has any information
to contact them okay ender thank you
now let's have a look at some of the
morning's other main stories for you
and the foreign office says it's
supporting the family of a british woman
killed in pakistan and is looking for
more information from local authorities
twenty-six-year-old mayra zelfika was
found dead at a home in the city of
lahore
after being shot local media reports
that she'd arrived in pakistan two
months ago and
reportedly feared for her life after
refusing marriage offers
from two men derek shoving the former
minneapolis police officer found guilty
of murdering george floyd has requested
a new trial
mr chauvin's lawyer said his client was
deprived of a fair trial
stating there was jury misconduct and
the verdict was contrary to law mr
chauvin who was captured on video
kneeling on mr floyd's neck for more
than nine minutes
was found guilty of murder and
manslaughter
two weeks ago
british supermarket chains have told
brazilian authorities they'll stop
sourcing products from its country if
the nation national congress votes to
bring in new laws
which threaten deforestation of the
amazon 40 country companies including
sainsbury's little and waitrose say
the changes will put the rainforest a
greater threat
than ever before
donald trump has returned to the
internet with his own communications
platform
titled from the desk of donald j trump
the former president was banned from
twitter and suspended by facebook and
youtube after the capital riots in
january
but a ruling expected today from
facebook's oversight board will announce
whether he can post to the platform once
again
just remind you you can catch up on the
day's big business news and interviews
on the ian king
business podcast available right now on
the sky news app
or wherever you get your podcasts
now the impact of climate change in one
california
county is alarming the authorities
following the driest year
in nine decades so much so
that in marin county mandatory water
restrictions have been imposed
as greg milan reports
in any normal year phoenix lake
reservoir would be nearly full around
now
today it's barely a third of that
the dry cracked mud the measure of what
officials say
is climate change in action in
california
i've been up here pretty frequently and
i think it's the last time was two or
three weeks ago and
just walking up here it's even drier
there's now an island in the middle of
our
reservoir that wasn't here when i was
here last time so you know we're
definitely seeing the impacts
we're in a historic drought right i mean
it's the driest you know 2020 was the
driest year in 90 years
this is um you know alarming and in some
ways i don't want to say expected but it
is
clearly you know tied to climate change
you know the changing climate
you know everything we know from the
scientists is that climate change is
going to bring us droughts that are more
frequent
and more severe and more intense and
that's what we're experiencing
phoenix lake is one of seven reservoirs
that provide water to marin county
so lower the levels they've imposed
mandatory water restrictions
200 000 residents told not to fill their
pools or hot tubs
and stop washing their cars jens had
already replaced his lawns with
artificial grass
solar tiles help power his home we have
to do it
see what's happening now is going to be
severe the restrictions he says
are essential i fully agree with it it
it has to otherwise we're not going to
get in here
uh i
it's hardship but certainly we can we
can live with it
from his house you can see the bridge
where in the 70s
they built a pipeline to bring water
across the bay
it's an option again now as the u s
government agency that monitors the seas
and atmosphere
confirmed an upward trend in average
temperatures almost all of this
the country's most populous state is in
drought much of it classed as extreme
it's clearly only getting worse because
we're
doing nothing about uh about climate
change as far as
restricting co2 going into the
atmosphere and
for all the talk and all the the best
intentions
we really aren't taking the action that
we need to take and we need to do it
right away
and about five miles away in the same
county sit the homes on stinson beach
which experts warn rising sea levels
could destroy within a generation
here the impacts of that climate change
future
have already arrived greg milam sky news
marin county in california
and a reminder you can see the daily
climate show later on today that's half
past six
and half past nine here on sky news
well let's see what the weather's going
to do over here it's not going to be
anything like that i'm afraid naz
is it a bit chilly today do we think
yeah it's going to be another cold one
we've got northerly winds
bringing through that cold air flow
temperatures disappointingly cool for
may around three degrees below for
what they should be this time of the
year and it's looking quite showery
again
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so it's a cool and showery
affair once again for today and for the
next couple of days friday looks like
the driest day of the week
but then as we head into the weekend
although it turns milder
it's going to be wet and windy once
again back to
right now and it's mostly dry for many
inland areas but
parts of northern scotland are
experiencing some rain and some
snow as well even down towards low
levels there's been reports of snow
to low levels of aberdeen for example
and across parts of northern ireland at
the northwest of the republic
western parts of wales and southwest of
england there are
showers showers scattered around some
eastern coastal counties too but as i
said inland areas mainly dry and bright
but
cold and frosty into this afternoon
those showers get going once again
they will become more widespread in
between dry and brighter spells and some
of them
could be thundery with a risk of hail
there will also
be the continuation of wintry showers
mainly across
northern hills so they will become
confined towards the high ground towards
low levels
rain showers are more likely it's going
to be disappointingly cool for the time
of year as i said initially
there will be a temperature highs around
three degrees below
average for what you'd expect for this
time of year and then tonight it's going
to be very chilly especially in the
north
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
yes thank you now the duchess of sussex
has written a children's book inspired
by the relationship between her husband
and son it's called the bench it's about
the bond between father and son
through a mother's eyes
there you go presumably that's harry got
ginger hair
in his uh in his uniform wrong sort of
cap that's an american cap i think
the deal comes after the couple signed a
contract with netflix and spotify
said to be worth more than a hundred
million
pounds well still to come on sky news
breakfast we're going to be talking
to the shadow working pension secretary
about labour's ambition
to drum up some last-minute votes ahead
of tomorrow's elections
[Music]
[Music]
please just make their first move and
they've gone in firing
again
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are hundreds of these turbines but
thousands more across gansung
that's what's left of the north tunnel
uh where the north koreans exploded five
nuclear warheads and this is a show of
strength
at a time when china is more fragile
than it has been at any time in recent
years
[Music]
shrapnel from that explosion you can see
it littered along
all the way we take you to the heart of
the stories that shape our world
the train station the airport they're
both closed we're not sure about the
roads we've seen reports
that they are being blocked by police so
we're going to try and find a way out
of wuhan after five days
stranded here this is deliverance we
help you
understand the world with us
tom cheshire sky news beijing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
now tomorrow's local elections will be
the first time the public can give their
verdict on labour's new leader sakia
stammer
many eyes are on the north of england
where strong support for brexit
helped the conservatives to break
through in areas that were traditionally
considered
labour heartlands and as our political
editor beth rigby reports
it looked like he's got his work cut out
in just a few days voters will go to the
polls for the first time since labour's
red wall
turned blue elections mid-parliament are
often difficult moments for the
governing party
but the conservatives are sitting
comfortably this time the tables are
turned
its labor and its leader under pressure
unless he can show that he can reverse
not just hold his place but reverse the
roads that we've already made into the
red wall
i think people within his own party will
really start asking the question
is this sort of metropolitan
representing the elite leader
the person who can win the red wall back
for labour and i think the answer to
that
sadly for kierstarma is absolutely not
when you've come up here are you
recognized or do people still
not know who you are oh it depends out
in east lancashire
kirsten knows he's up against it you're
going to have a really bad election
aren't you
look we're sailing into a very strong
headwind because
um there's undoubtedly a vaccine bounce
for the government
but we've lost four elections and
therefore over a
longer term there's been a sense
that the labour party is not close
enough to those
communities to those that we want to
vote for us and that's what we've got to
do to close that gap and re-establish
that
now i do think that can be done in one
general election cycle and that's what
we are doing
the key red fights for you are the
westminster mayor
the tease valley mayor and hartley paul
if you lose all three of them how
serious the trouble are you in as a
leader
i've got a huge task ahead of me there's
no doubt
taking the labour party from where we
were the worst results since 1935
in december 2019 into a position where
we can win an election
is a huge task it is going to take
time i never thought that we could
achieve that in one year i don't think
anybody
realistically thought we could do it in
one year
but i do believe that we're making
progress and heading in the right
direction
these elections will be the first chance
for the public to give their verdict on
kierstama
since he was elected labour leader just
over a year ago
he likes to say that the party's under
new leadership
but the question is have the public
really noticed and if they have
do they like what they see excuse me
hi i'm i'm beth from sky i was just
wondering that man over there do you
know who he is
the guy over there no no it's kierstarma
right do you know who he is no idea okay
a year in the job sir kia is struggling
to cut through to voters
kirsten was up here today i don't know
if you heard he was out and about
what do you think of him to be honest i
think he's just another one yeah
so they're all of the same similar breed
gonna do the same similar job
i don't know if kiersten was making that
much of an impact it doesn't seem to
have made much of an impact on you
i think it's down to individual
characters and there is
still the big divide of westminster and
the rest of the world
but some politicians have made their
mark to be honest
they're quite like boris johnson as a
character
um i think he's borderline semi-normal
the pandemics made normal politics all
but impossible
in times of crisis the public have
little patience for party posturing
but how labor fares in its traditional
heartlands will be
its acid test it's in their old red wall
where they must prove they can build
back
beth rigby sky news
well this is a full list of the
candidates standing
in the hartley pool by-election you can
find further information about the
election
at hartley pool.gov dot uk
and sky news will be covering all the
very latest on the uk elections
beginning with the hartlepool
by-election from midnight on thursday
with the results right through the
weekend
let's talk to the shadow work and
pension secretary
jonathan redles who joins us now it's
good to see you
this morning look how concerned are you
that you know
certainly looking at the polls you're
not making the inroads that
you should be mid-government well
good morning yes first of all let me say
on paul's
look i've had elections where you know
they were supposed to win and that's
what the polls said
it didn't work out that way so you've
got to wait till the actual contest
i would say you know a lot of those
conservative pollings that we've seen
are really down to turn out um
quite rightly historically conservative
supporters more likely to vote
than labour supporters or we've got to
say to people who want good public
services and good local leaders
we need you out there to vote when the
polls open tomorrow but
i think it is fair to say to answer your
question directly that
it's not been the kind of year as an
opposition party that you would want in
terms of the chance to talk about wider
things to talk about
how you lost the last general election
pretty
badly but that's just how it is there's
no use complaining about that
we still feel very confident that we've
got the right things for the country
we've got some great candidates standing
we've got some incumbent
mayors and councillors who've really
defended their communities in the
pandemic and also some new candidates
standing too so that we recognize it's
hard we want people to look at us and
say
we see they're under new leadership
things have improved since 2019 we're
willing to listen to them again that's
all we ask
and let's see where we get to tomorrow
when the polls do open
i mean you said you've not had the
chance to to talk about what you want to
talk about and looked
understandable that mean the pandemic
has has dominated everything
and yet when over the last few weeks
when there has been a chance to really
set out your stall
you've focused on allegations around
number 10 now
they might be important but people still
need to know what you stand for rather
than what you're against
don't they well that's true i mean let
me just say on
the sleazer and corruption and the
funding stuff around the government
look as an opposition party those things
do matter you don't do them for
electoral effect you do them because
standards and integrity in public life
should matter and it is our job to make
sure the government is
certainly obeying the law but also
setting the right standards people
expecting so that's not about elections
that's about what the what the right
thing is for this country in terms of
how this government operates
in terms of the positive yes but look i
mean i'm sitting at home here
in stately bridge andy murder andy
burnham is the mayor of greater
manchester he has made a massive
difference on homelessness on
housing he stood up to the government in
the pandemic well they were going to
offer us
a much worse deal on furlough than the
rest of the country so we can we can
save with pride your
labor representatives have made a
difference and we can say that message
across all parts of the uk so i do
there's a positive message there as well
fundamentally that's about making sure
we we build something
better from this pandemic than what we
had going into it because i think many
of the real burdens of the pandemic
have been felt by people because of the
state of public services going into the
crisis of
job insecurity of how fragile people's
lives were we've got to build something
better around that so we're putting that
positive case
but of course we're holding the
government to account to when they fall
below
the necessary standards in public life i
find it quite interesting that you
you talk about the local candidates and
of course they're the people
putting their their heads above the
parapet with all of this but
this is seen isn't it as a judgment on
sakia stammer
as the new labour leader um and it's not
looking like the people are
taking to him particularly there's a a
surveillation poll has him with a
a rating of minus 18.
well it is about uh the local candidates
that are standing with us council
candidates mayors
the welsh labour government and
hopefully a stronger platform for us
in scotland but we all know there's
always a bit of commentaries in there
about the the national political parties
the
local elections are always a little bit
more than just about the
locality uh in terms of kia key is an
asset to the labour party i mean he is
someone the public see
as a potential prime minister we haven't
always had that to be frank when it
comes to
labour leaders so people like here i
think what they want to know now is what
what the future will be what is that
wider platform from the party what are
us as
is kia's shadow cabinet able to offer
people as well and hopefully we'll get a
chance to do that but
we're under no illusions how how big the
defeat was in 2019 and how
big the challenge ahead of us is we just
want to see some progress and i can say
with real honesty and genuineness the
response from people when we knock on
their doors and certainly my experience
in all parts of the country
has been much warmer than it was in 2019
people are at least willing i think that
to listen to us to have that
conversation we would have looked to
have had more of them you know we'd love
to have had
uh the kind of mobilization of our big
army of activists that you would usually
have in elections like this
that hasn't been possible again you just
that's just how it is no use complaining
about that
but we have been constrained frankly
from what we ideally would have been
able to do
okay jonathan rails good to talk to you
thank you thank you
i've still to come on sky news breakfast
this morning with the government's green
travel list due soon we ask whether the
pandemic has made some of us
too nervous to go abroad
you know it all started with einstein
developing theory of general relativity
and then you know the first idea
you know i had in 25 years ago and then
we had to build a big collaboration of
an
international team with 350 scientists
working together with eight
telescopes on six different mountains
across the world
and then analyzing the data for almost
two years
until we came out and
this was just the end point of a long
journey and hopefully a beginning of a
you know a new era that we're going into
doing physics at the edge of black holes
this is really a new thing we do
this is the most extreme gravity you can
have and we know that our
theory is incomplete at the edge of
black holes that the
theory of the very big the theory of
general relativity that describes
space and time and the theory of the
quantum world that describes matter and
light and everything that we touch today
they don't go together at the edge of
black holes
and what we now see is we see that
darkness
you know in the middle of that image
that's where the light disappears in the
event horizon where information
disappears and never comes back
and that what makes it so so special
it's sort of the end of space and time
you're looking at and we now we actually
see it
you know it was a theory as you said
until you know a few years ago
this was just theory and now we have
hard
physical evidence that you know this
event horizon is there
and provides a final boundary frontier
of our knowledge i mean if you go to the
edge of a black hole
and he would see someone fall in you
would see that person go slower and
slower
is his or her clock would just go slower
and slower and vice versa if i would be
hovering above a black hole
i would see the rest of the universe
speed up you know i i
could see you know thousands of years
suddenly pass
in in a few minutes and you think that
it's just you know
crazy but it actually happens even in
our
daily lives without us noticing it
because you know if you use the
navigation system
your gps navigation system we're using
clocks
up in space and they actually go faster
up in space than when they were launched
when they were on the ground so they
actually said wrong on purpose
so that you know when they are launched
up there and there's less gravity and
less curvature of space time
they actually go just right
for the early the headline risers
the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertainment
podcast
for wherever you are welcome to safety
ridge what's on sunday podcast
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know symptoms of hay
fever can develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by phillips connected air
purifiers
this afternoon will be another day of
sunshine and showers
some of the showers will be wintry over
northern hills whilst others will be
heavy and thundery with a risk of hail
particularly across the north and east
of the uk
where it'll remain windy elsewhere winds
will be lighter than recently but it'll
be a cold day
everywhere pollen levels will be
moderate pretty much everywhere again
with tree pollen currently airborne
a mixture of birch oak and ash plain
pollen is likely in some cities too
and spores will increase temporarily
after any showers
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
now many of us are of course excited
about at least the possibility of a
summer holiday and the aviation industry
is
certainly desperate to get more planes
back into the sky
but for some this year's great british
summer will be
best spent here in great britain jemima
walker went to find out whether a year
of lockdowns has caused some people to
be hesitant
about the prospect of international
travel
we'll soon find out which golden sands
will be given the green light
but after last year's travel chaos many
back in britain
say they won't be booking an overseas
holiday
good god
why would people go on holidays i mean
you're taking your life in your hands
nobody really knows what's going on
things are so changeable at the moment
and um
yeah we're making alternative
arrangements you know in
england i just think with how quickly
the virus can move and change as it did
in this country back in november
december
i'd rather not risk that and then have
to quarantine coming back 14 days plus
pcr test costs
potentially a few hundred quid for a
family a trade body representing travel
agents says pent up demand
is there people just need clarity
the best thing is to speak with a travel
professional someone who can guide you
through
what's happening in the world of travel
at the moment and speak with them to
help
you make your decision on that holiday
and that should give the reassurance
that you know
the latest on what's going on and
perhaps the best move for you for your
family
uh whoever you may be going abroad with
perhaps later this year
while tourists are uncertain for
families separated by the pandemic
it's a different story sisters tamzin
and katie
haven't seen each other since 2019.
tamzin lives in malta and is getting
married this summer
she desperately hopes her family can be
there
there's been a lot of talk in the uk
about malta being put on the green list
um but it's like a carrot in front of
your
your face um dangling it in front of
there and not actually being able to
bite it
it's not easy it's definitely definitely
not easy it's like in the uk
everybody had those christmas plans and
think how they felt when those christmas
plans were taken away from them
that's happening to us every three or
four months every time
so there's a travel story and all yep
travel's allowed all yet you're gonna be
and then it gets taken away we have to
go through that constantly
and we still don't know if we're going
to get to see each other in august
certainty is hard to come by during a
pandemic
but it's what holiday makers the tourist
industry
and separated families all say they need
jeremiah marwaka sky news
now one of the countries that could be
on the government's green list
is israel which has had a highly
successful vaccination program
well let's talk to the head of the
israeli government's tourist office in
london
sharon bashadski good to see you this
morning
uh i mean where is israel positioned at
the moment should should it get a green
light from the uk
would israel actually want us to visit
oh israel definitely ready and and wants
the the british tourists to visit
um i think like a bit not like other
country
we declared um a gradual opening a
gradual and a safe opening
um it's it's very i don't know if it's
easy but it's very simple just to say
okay we we open up the country everyone
are invited
as a head of the tourist board i wish i
could say that
but um we will do it a bit more
gradually we're starting with a pilot
only for groups um this month in may
um if it worked well hopefully it will
be more than a pilot for books and
hopefully
for the summer holiday we will be ready
for individuals coming to visit israel
uh what do we know what the requirements
will be in terms of a vaccination
passport or negative covid testing what
would
has israel establish what it will
require from brits
we we will require from the tourists to
be fully vaccinated
when we say fully vaccinated within two
doses
in addition to i guess the standard pcr
and in addition to that
when coming to israel we will require an
antibody test
just to confirm everything is there and
the everything works with the the
vaccine because it's very very hard
maybe it's more simple from some
countries but for some other countries
it's a bit more challenging to
make sure all the documentation of the
vaccination
is fully um approved so to
to be completely sure we require this
test and we
will eliminate this test in the future
hopefully
by a bilateral agreement between
countries so for example
um if the um if israel and the uk will
have this agreement
the british tourists that will come to
israel will not need
this antibody test and i'm really really
hoping
with the impressive um
uh advanced uh um pace of the
vaccination here in the uk we will get
this agreement as soon as possible
so it is okay israel is working on the
basis of individual agreements with
individual countries and to
to allow people in and allow your
population to travel as well
yes the israeli people i think very
similar to the british people
cannot wait to go abroad some of them
started to for countries that is
possible
so um there there is a green pass in
israel we
mainly use it at the moment for domestic
tourism
so basically israel is completely open
people are traveling
ancient jerusalem and partying in tel
aviv and going to restaurants and
traveling the
the train and and to the sunny city of
the lot
it's 28 degrees in tel aviv people are
traveling
using um their green pass to enter
places and they are also using and will
use it more and more in the future
the green pass to to go and travel
abroad and also come back with no
isolation
and hopefully the second the um the
tourists will be able to
to come inside in is to israel gradually
from
this month um they will be able to
download something similar to the green
pass to the app that the israelis are
using
and enter all of the places the museums
the the restaurants
the the clubs and so on okay
good to talk to you thank you we look
forward to visiting
whenever we can we can't wait
okay let's get a check on the weather
for you now here's that
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's another cool and
showery affair
across the uk and island for today and
in fact into tomorrow as well
friday looks like the driest day of the
weekend
but then beyond that it is looking wet
and windy
into the weekend in fact it is also
going to turn
a bit milder but very wet and windy
conditions are expected
so for this morning it's a chilly start
out there for many areas largely dry
across
inland parts but there are frosty
conditions
there are some showers around across
parts of northern ireland the north west
the republic the north of scotland where
there's snow falling even down towards
low levels of scotland currently and
also
across parts of the west of wales and
southwest england there are some showers
around some eastern coastal counties so
it's mainly around the edges
of the uk and ireland inland areas are
mostly dry but going into this afternoon
much like the last few days
cloudier skies will develop showers will
become more widespread some of them will
be heavy thundery with a risk of hail it
will be
disappointingly cool for the time of
year as well
the weather sponsored by qatar airways